Okay ladies, here's the first question.
I'm gonna go on a big trip next week and I just wanna know from you...
...what are the three most important things you think I should pack?
Clothes, pack some clothes, okay.
And a toothbrush.
You can have a hat.
Do you think? What kind of hat?
A fancy hat.
I'll get that on my list.
What's the best way to greet someone if you don't speak the same language?
Shake hands.
Blink or...
Smile!
What do you think a smile does?
You can give hope to them.
You give them hope?
Aw, that's so sweet.
What would you say to someone who says girls aren't allowed to go to school?
Boys and girls need to be treated equally.
Yeah, they need to be treated equally.
How would you feel if someone told you you couldn't go to school?
Why do you think they need to go to school?
To learn.
To get educated.
And do math.
And do some math.
I think we've covered it.
We got them all.
How would you sum up your experience today?